foreign
[Music]
it's been a while besides may I say
being in some of the doing some of the
best football commentary he really does
like out of any analyst in a while and
it's not just because we're marks for
[__] Michael Strahan now but just
legit because a lot of them are either
[__] or annoying and he just has a
like he's because he's fine I love
football well because he went over to
like GMA and you could tell he really
refined his like broadcaster side and
his goofing aside but that [__]
knows football and still watches every
[__] game so he's not like a guy
that's like coming in like no I kind of
watched the spike he's like did you see
that play last week Oh you mean when
they tried a shoehorn Frank Caliendo
because he did a John Madden but he knew
nothing about football that was so
annoying it's like oh he does John
Madden he'll be great for the football
show meanwhile Australian's like I've
seen this kid playing college yeah two
years ago in a game against Stanford I
remember in the third quarter he like
dude this guy watches every football
game
hey Michael
hey George that's right I'm here to
report on how Okay is being affected by
climate change but just
he's clearly there yeah
but have I just been psyopped to the
point where it still just feels like a
green screen yeah like his feet are
clearly undergrades clearly there but
every time I look at somebody now and I
see the good lighting I'm like is that a
green I I just everything's fake they
don't even do anything in the white
house anymore
I don't believe he's driving exists
there you go I don't believe that no I
thought I literally never heard of it
until the critic yeah I'm not sure why
let's hear why climate change is
affecting [__] the earth I guess new
Statue was found partially due to those
changing conditions and this morning
a new Statue was found because of uh
because climate change well well well
how about thank you SUV owners you know
what how about thank you yeah I was just
gonna say I mean
that's an X that's one more statue right
and places that you could in farm are
going to become warm you're going to be
able to farm how about your welcome yeah
how about uh how about you're welcome
how about I drive a gas guzzling SUV now
so I'd like to thank you for bringing
the sea levels back to where they were
prior when people were building statues
there seems to me like it's a return to
normalcy my AC is at 69. oh dude
first of all nice thank you oh dude oh
dude
um sometimes in the summer my cats they
just like the outside they like the
smells I'll crack the windows when it's
hot out just run the air you know what I
do gas fireplace when it's cold outside
but open the door so it gets a little
cold in there still inside I like to
battle can I um can't be honest with you
I've been looking at one of those LED
ones that we see yeah yeah yeah and I'm
like I'll run the air so cold but have
warm spots because that's what we do
that's how we roll in Florida thank you
SUV owners we still use coal
yeah
enjoy thank you just as I am making my
way to report on the effect climate
change is happening on Easter Island he
looks so bizarre when the person he's
interacting with also happens to be
bizarrely tiny because he's so huge and
a little Asian lady's like thank you for
your ticket now I was Denise the island
and I was surprised there was no candied
eggs or rabbits very very surprised that
it's nothing like the holiday George
Stephanopoulos is on the phone with
Soros going do you have those reanimated
zombies of Easter Island ready to attack
him please this is the next level he
comes back so the reanimated island
zombies uh turns out you know they're
not such bad guys owner he's the king of
the island Zone we got to talking about
you know Easter Island and they were
shocked at my knowledge of the history
of the islands also big Giants fans got
them tickets they have been friends now
so I'm King of the Easter Island zombie
people I know in this one he's not even
like wow so you're the king of that nah
but they don't let me be king because
I'm not a zombie but they made me an
honorary remember they said that I am
welcome to come in here and engage and
trade with them at any time I have all
the perfect success I'm not allowed at
the flesh eating festivals which is fine
because that's more of a holy holiday
and I understand and I'm doing more of a
keto thing now anyway so I'm just gonna
[__] it's literally every evil force
in the world that Stephanopoulos has
tried to unite against yeah and they
just end up going Australian guys all
right
the incredible finding a previously
undiscovered moai statue newly on Earth
you're welcome you know the things that
we do for this planet go unnoticed my
truck gets 20 miles to the gallon
highway you're welcome that's you the
first of its kind ever found in this
dried up lake bed once full of water yes
that's what a dried up lake bed is Lake
Rondo rodraku has completely evaporated
oh man that's the running back on my
fantasy team
the last two years do in part to climate
change
a recent fire incinerating the dried up
vegetation unveiling the statue hidden
beneath for centuries there have been no
more does that not feel like some kind
of weird Omen it does maybe it's not
climate change maybe it's like the fact
that we're just trying to start World
War III and burning everything into the
ground and
found in what was previously it turns
out I uncovered the first deal in the
Book of Revelation
uh so this is this is uh a first we
could see more new discoveries of moai
from the lake bed and under the present
dry condition so let's get to this that
was that was uh this is a little more
recent and Easter Island there you see
it right there sunrise over Easter
Island we just learned that at the same
time there as it is here but the sun is
in a different how is it so it's it's
how do time zones work
is that what you're asking that's
strange maybe Michael can explain it to
us but Michael you brought us on such an
adventure now you have some special
guests oh no he did become king of the
Easter Island people Jesus [__]
Christ they're about to do something
they are now following me oh no oh no
that's what happened didn't it as well
it has been an event that's right and by
the way George I'm just gonna come right
out and say it these people came clean
and uh I know it's been new this whole
time so uh I'm taking the the mayori
people here and the space [__] and all
these [__] puffins puffins we
coming for you man some more people the
mole people everybody I made friends
with we come with the polar bears are
coming everyone's coming
that's the final It's the final like you
know that third Avengers the third act
Showdown where all the Avengers Assemble
and it's just gonna be Michael Strahan's
swarming New York City with this weird
Army to come get George Stephanopoulos
all that to you but I don't know
everything but it's gonna look like
[__] Lord of the Rings it would be so
dope Yeah final showdown
it has been I gotta say you got it it
has been so incredible to learn about
this place and it's Rich culture and a
part of that is music and dance we got a
little taste of it earlier in the show
but I'm here now I did not realize these
people still dress like them
he's the director it was a shock to me
that I saw this man's testicles as soon
as I met him bro it's more like
embarrassing like when you go you ever
been to like an Indian Powwow
like what like in the prairie no like
like they have them anywhere where you
live near like Indian reservations
they'll have a powwow once in a while
I've never been in one of them they had
them all like all those drum things they
do like yeah yeah I know what you're
talking about I've never been wondering
what you're talking about like I've been
to a powwow before on Long Island and it
was because it wasn't just a powwow
there was like a circus there and then
it was like a [__] trade circus swap
meet show thing it was a whole bunch of
[__] going on but there was a pow out
there isn't it kind of like in 2020 is
it 2023 kind of embarrassing to be doing
like a weird Minstrel show of like your
people my people my people like it's I
would be embarrassed like if I was like
a black guy I wouldn't want to dress up
like uh like uh Kamala and [__] Chuck
a spear and be like I wish it was the
Bob Burton I wish
Burton it just it's just weird to do it
to this day and be like yeah it's part
of the show we still dressing [__]
leather loincloth and collect arrowheads
it's like dude the [__] world's
ending man maybe stop I think these
dudes obviously dress normal they do
this just for like this step because
these guys this guy's on steroids back
here these guys do it for like TV and
stuff I'm saying they have Indian
reservations over this [__] do
it for real right why are you doing this
thank you for being here my friend and
um you know you've been singing and
dancing since you were a baby since you
were a kid so how long have you been gay
pass on the traditional Rapa Nui music
and song to the Future Generations I'm
gonna tell you about first good morning
in America
we say hello from here from rapanui this
beautiful wow he's taking over the
interview this guy's an absolute rapanui
Chad yes yeah the name of the group is
what means which means Creed in our
language we had the name first I want to
be clear
before that [__] Scott piece of [__]
Scott stamp started that [__] band
gee the power of the book we were
diverse we were the first Creed
coincidentally also my first album was
called My Own Prison yeah
yeah anyway it is Wonder World anyway
Here's My Own Prison
it sounds nothing like the Korean
version we are Polynesians and then we
practice that you know there is a part
of me that roots for people like this
deep down and there's part of me that
kind of wants
the final the final count
uh I I kind of want Chinese American and
Russian nukes to all go off at once give
us the Fallout reset and I'm just hoping
that like little groups like this kind
of survive and we start over like like
when you just get so sick of like
winning in Civilization but you know
yeah like continuing to take over the
world you're like I'm done I did good on
this one you just want to start over
again I just want to have dudes with
sticks bow and arrow again let's start
over I'm bored like I'm bored with
Society we just nuke it and then hope
like tribes like this survive playing a
little ukulele start fresh showing
people from horseback with a bow and
arrow
way and you guys take it away
here we go are you attacking uh they're
attacking shoot them with our guns oh
that's right we have handguns they could
do nothing dude strains private security
is just a little too twitching
that guy has a pearl drumstance
[Music]
wow that song kind of sucks I'm sorry
Virgie has a good point yes
like the traditional Easter Island
people have always had Virgie
idiot
read a history book sometime I really
appreciate Virgie having that lens that
none of us have which is just yeah like
he can spot [__] that it is
now it's bugging me hands
yo you couldn't hold them [__] like
Bongos or some [__] Bro Virgie would be
one of the biggest pains in the asses
and also assets on any production yeah
you'd be like oh cool so you're doing
the scene in the 1920s and he's got a
pearl Trust
does he have a [__] a Les Paul too
you [__] so let me get this straight
right Ralph Macchio we're supposed to
pretend he's a he's really good at
guitar how about he hits the [__]
notes right I don't care who you have
playing over him bro it's bro it's a
joey jordison signature stand it's
Savage
[Laughter]
turns out they're all traditional Maori
people except the guy on drums he's just
one of the percussionists from Slipknot
that got fired he wouldn't get the vacs
[Music]
it was arrested development
[Applause]
all right now it's just noise okay keep
it down sounds like a joke
[__] track yes
anyway we'll be performing at the Easter
Island hooters this weekend
they work at whatever [__] version of
a Jiffy Lube is on that island I see you
guys have been working on your dancing
now you should work on your music
this song kind of [__] sucks how long
are we filming I have to go back to work
at the Cold Stone Creamery
like why are we still doing that stuff
though
uh I don't know how is it supposed to
stop climate change I love that one out
of touch Good Morning America has gotten
though where they're doing all this [__]
while the world is just like we're
literally
teetering towards disaster and
everyone's poor and sad and miserable
made a made a good point they're just
they're just like they're they're the
North Dakota to South Dakota as [__]
as as Easter Island is to [__] Hawaii
they're just copying Hawaii and trying
to be Hawaii it's Hawaii but no one
wants to go there yeah Easter Island
doesn't have a culture because nobody
lives there no that's a good point